hey everybody and welcome to planet zoo
this will be my first blended zoo
time-lapse
so it's kind of a special moment but at
the same time this is a very simple
video and quite sure if you compare it
to my usual videos you're probably
wondering why this is less than ten
minutes I mean how am I gonna make any
money off of mid-roll ads if I'm not
even reaching ten minutes and besides
there's not too much that you can do in
ten minutes but this is really the kind
of content that I want to try and make
for the planet zubeida given the fact
that the beta will only last for two
weeks and after that there will be
somewhat of a radio silence where we
can't play the game anymore so whatever
I do I want to keep my projects quite
short and simple for the beta just to
explore the pieces see what's possible
in the game and of course also trying to
make some small zoo elements maybe I'll
make a small two or three parter series
I'm just gonna have to see what I feel
like doing but whatever I'm going to do
I want to keep everything quite simple
and short just to make sure that I don't
run out of time until the end of the
beta and besides we might lose
everything that we do now when the full
game comes out frontier isn't sure
whether they're gonna be able to support
blueprints coming out in the beta in the
full game so I'm gonna have to build
everything with the assumption that I
won't be able to save it and I'm gonna
lose it at some point so for that reason
I just want to feel a bit more free to
just kind of do whatever I feel like
doing in the spur of the moment and in
this case that was a Japanese teahouse
so I'm building a Japanese teahouse and
that's basically it won't be ending
anything around it really or I won't be
building it on it in any way now I
should probably talk a little bit about
this tea house what it is and why I
decided to build a Japanese teahouse
well for one I guess at this point a
little bit infamous for building
something Japanese in every simulation
game I come across and I tried to
restrain myself when it comes to planets
ooh but in the end as you can see it
only took one day for me to build
something Japanese so we're already here
we got this over with and now that the
Japanese theme is all done I guess I can
move on to other ideas so partly it's
just because I really wanted to do it
partly it's also because I realized that
it's doable because well when the game
came out and when I was doing my live
stream for a few hours just recording
some of my first gameplay I didn't
realize that in the franchise mode which
I'm currently in you can actually
research scenery pieces and pretty much
get all of the scenery pieces that are
available in the beta so even though we
don't have a sandbox mode in the beta
this is as close to a sandbox mode as
you can get I think given the fact that
we can get all of the pieces and it's a
completely flat map with some money even
though it's very limited so I have to
watch out regarding my budget it's
somewhat of a sandbox mode so I think
that works alright and when I was
looking at the pieces that I researched
specifically the Indian ones actually
because that's where I got the tile
roofs from that you can see at the top
here I realized that Japanese
architecture would probably be doable
and so even though it's not in the game
at least not at the moment I have no
idea about full release although it
would be really cool to see an East
Asian wall pack of some sort
I figured for now it's probably possible
and especially the type of building
which I'm building here which is if I
pronounced it correctly a cheat suit
which is a traditional tea house and
these buildings tend to be quite subdued
very simple well not necessarily simple
but not overly detailed or well with
ridiculous curved Asian roofs as they
are stereotypically known for or any
detailing or even painted elements
everything is quite simple
using just natural elements and textures
a lot comes down to how you place the
details rather than just how much you
place down and the general composition
of the building at the end of the day
they are typically very simple buildings
just for tea ceremonies with a lot of
Shoji walls that you can move around
Shoji being this combination of Japanese
paper and bamboo making these grid like
patterns of windows walls and doors that
you can move around on the floor to
rearrange the layouts of buildings
because in a lot of traditional Japanese
architecture you don't really have the
solid walls that you see in Western
architecture buildings are much more
flexible much more open and they can
move a lot of the walls around and
especially on a good day open the entire
building sets something that should
realistically also be possible for the
building which I'm building right now
that's why I am making it look the way
that I am right now and making some of
these Shoji screens using his stucco
pieces and wooden beams which is not the
best solution to try and make these but
I think especially from a distance it
looks convincing enough now I will be
closing this entire building just
because I don't want to deal with
interiors or anything that would be
really difficult given the fact that the
interior is kind of a warbot mess of
different wooden posts or bumbling into
each other just because I needed them
like that to make the exterior so I'm
just closing the whole building off but
I'm trying to make it look as though we
have all of these walls and doors and
windows that can actually move around
and rearrange the building
and typically in real life I think you
find a lot of these buildings in
Japanese gardens as well be it in a tea
garden which is typically just a single
path winding through a gun and toward a
tea house or one of these lake style
gardens where you have a path walking
around the lake and you'll often find a
tea house somewhere alongside the lake
or even in the middle of the lake in
some cases and yeah it's this kind of
setting where I think you'll find a lot
of these types of buildings so I was
thinking about building a Japanese
garden around it to make it look even
more like it's in a context that you'll
usually find it in real life but given
the fact that this franchise mode map is
in the Asian grassland biome and we
don't really have any green grass that
looks convincingly like it could be
somewhere in Japan I didn't want to
build an entire garden and around it
I'll be placing down a few rocks and
some foliage that I think looks Japanese
ish but that's really just about it I
don't think I can push it much further
than that and as you can see at this
point the building is pretty much
already finished and the setup is very
simple we've got a front here with that
roof overhanging a bit more than the
rest of the building but you can
actually walk around the entire building
and this slightly raised wooden walkway
I also I am super glad actually for the
fact that we have these wooden floors
that are very thin a lot of the wooden
floor pieces in planet coaster that are
on the grid are very thick and in this
case having this thin wooden floor
actually helps alone in making this
building much more realistic I think
otherwise I would have been forced to
make these floors out of some kind of
scenery piece and that would have been a
lot more difficult not to mention that
I'm trying to keep the piece count as
low as possible for this building
because I wanted to upload it on the
blue on the workshop as a blueprint so
it shouldn't be too expensive to be
affordable and also I'm very limited in
terms of my budgets so if I start making
roofs out of wooden core balls like I
did in planet coaster I'm gonna run out
of budget real
so I have to do these things kind of by
being smart about the placement of
scenery and not necessarily by putting a
bunch of different scenery elements
together and shaping a different element
with it so anyway this is the small very
minor Japanese garden ish environment I
guess then I was building around the
building
it's not exactly a great Japanese going
and I have to say it's also lacking a
lot of typical foliage although I am
very glad that we got the cherry blossom
tree in the game which is absolutely
beautiful it's the the pink blossom tree
up there
on the top right and it looks really
amazing I love that one probably going
to use that one a bit more often but
yeah the rest is just some shrubs that I
sunk into the ground some simple rock
work to kind of symbolize the mountains
and some Scots pines
then I'm trying to imitate Japanese pine
trees with and with that said that is
the entire build so I'd like to thank
you guys for watching if you're
interested in checking this build out
you can find it on the Steam Workshop
I'll leave a link down in the
description and I hope to see you guys
in the next planet soo video bye guys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]